- [Instructor] We are told
that Tony has 2/3 of a bag
of dark chocolate chips
and 4/5 of a bag of white chocolate chips.
Determine a reasonable estimate
of the total amount of
chocolate chips Tony has.
So pause this video
and see if you can figure
out which of these choices
is the best reasonable estimate
of the total amount of chocolate chips.
All right, now let's
work on this together.
Now in the future,
we will learn how to actually
add something like 2/3
to 4/5, but for the sake of this exercise,
we just want to get good at estimating it.
And one way to estimate
is to try to visualize.
So let's make,
so this is a whole right over here,
and then this is another
whole right over there.
Try to make them the same size.
Now what does 2/3 look like?
Well, let me divide this
into three equal sections,
so that is pretty close.
It's hand drawn, so it's not perfect,
but I think it gets the job done.
And 2/3 would be, that's
1/3 right over there
and then that is 2/3 right there,
and what does 4/5 looks like?
Well, let's see.
I can divide this into fifths,
so 1/5, 2/5,
3/5, and then 4/5, and 5/5.
That is pretty good.
And now what does 4/5 look like?
Well, it would be 1/5,
2/5, 3/5, and then 4/5.
So if we were to add these two together,
do we have less than 1/2 of a bag,
more than 1/2 of a bag,
but less than one bag,
or more than one bag?
Well, when you see even the first 2/3,
where is a half?
A half would have been right around there
if we're talking about half of it.
So 2/3 is more than a half,
and then we also see that
4/5 is more than a half.
If you had a half,
it would have been like this far.
So you can see that you're
adding two things together
that are both more than a half.
And if you have two halves of
something, that'd be a whole,
so if you have two things
that are more than a half,
if you add them together,
you're gonna have more than
a bag of chocolate chips.
So I like this choice right over here.
Let's do another example.
So here, we are told
that a banana weights 3/8 of a kilogram,
an apple weighs 2/3 of a kilogram.
Determine a reasonable estimate
for the weight of both fruits.
So pause this video again
and see if you can have a go at that.
All right, so the key is that we need
to determine a reasonable estimate.
So let's actually just try
to represent these again,
so how could I represent 3/8 of something,
of a kilogram, in this case?
Well, let me draw a rectangle here
and I'm going to try to
divide it into eighths,
eight equal sections,
so that looks about a half.
Let me do it right over there.
That looks like about a half,
and then if I were to divide those,
these would be fourths,
and this is hand drawn,
so it's not perfect,
but it will help us
understand things a bit.
So then let me divide these,
and so this would get me to eighths.
So I have eight sections here.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
and if I'm talking about three
of those eight equal sections,
I'd have 1/8, 2/8, and 3/8,
so that is 3/8 right over there
and what does 2/3 looks like?
So I'll do that in purple,
so if this is a whole,
this is a whole like that.
If I divide it into three equal sections,
it's going to be something like that.
I could draw it a little bit better,
so something like that,
and so two of those three equal sections,
that's 1/3, and so that is 2/3.
Now what happens if I try to
add these things together?
Well one thing I could try
to do to help visualize
is I could take that piece there.
The wholes are roughly the same length
or I tried to draw them
so that they are roughly the same length,
and if I were to copy and paste that
and move that over here,
it looks like, if I were to estimate it,
I'm getting pretty close
to a whole kilogram here.
So it's definitely not just
about 1/3 of a kilogram.
1/3 of a kilogram would be just one
of these three equal sections.
We're way more than that,
so we rule that out.
About one kilogram, that's what we saw.
When we,
when we take the 2/3 and add to that, 3/8,
where it looks like, and
once again, we're estimating.
We don't know exactly.
It looks like we're a
little bit over a kilogram,
so I like this choice,
and we're no where close to two kilograms.
Two kilograms, we would be
filling in another whole
on top of this one right over here.
So it's not that choice either.